in the tightly contested state of
florida
emotions are running high vote for trump
like true americans
socialism trump and biden went head to
head here
so too did their supporters we've been
getting middle finger stuff thrown at us
all
for the past hour and a half that we've
been here if joe biden
wins florida in the election he's not
gonna will you accept it
president the united states as america
was supposed to but
guess what it's not going to happen what
do you say to people who say
you're being intimidating you should let
people have a choice
i mean everybody has the right to choice
everybody everybody again the people
that were at the biting rally today when
we seen them hi how you doing
who's the losers now trump fans are
unwelcome
guests at a biden rally at times
aggravation sparks confrontation
one of the trump supporters said that
you spat on him
that what then you spat on him he
kept coming in our car and we told him
not to we had to do something to get him
away
do you feel sad that this is what it's
come down to oh absolutely
it didn't have to be this is not going
to be the worst you think it's going to
get worse
when biden wins next week trump's going
to say it was rigged and he's going to
tell all his people that you know have
guns to go out and start
protecting their liberty my president
is a racist racist
if you ever wonder just how bitter this
fight has become this is a prime example
we're just days away from the election
and in tight states like this
the tension's continuing to rise this is
democracy in america
but compromise and compassion seem in
short supply
a dangerous trend when in just days
one side is expected to accept defeat
siobhan robbins sky news in florida